why didn't they just give you the right
scoop size
it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd and skin care
nerd
the ordinary are a skincare brand that's
famous for their giant range of
budget-friendly
simple mostly active ingredient focused
products
and i like a lot of ordinary products so
i've talked before about the squalane
cleanser the natural moisturizing
factors cream
and the seven percent glycolic acid
toning solution they've recently
launched a hundred percent niacinamide
powder
and they've had their 100% l-ascorbic
acid powder for a while
and today i'm going to be telling you
why i don't recommend them
if you like this sort of nerdy beauty
content click the thumbs up subscribe
and click the nerdification bell so you
don't miss any videos
so overall i really like deciem and the
ordinary
i like a lot of their products i like a
lot of ordinary products i also like a
lot of niod products and hylamide
products
and i really appreciate the fact that
deciem and the ordinary in general
are really emphasizing understanding the
science behind the ingredients you're
using
but their powders are something that
i've never really gotten on board with
so this is the hundred percent
niacinamide powder which is new and the old
100% L-ascorbic acid powder
these are both pr samples and hopefully
i don't get blacklisted for being honest
because that has happened before
anyway let's talk about them now
so firstly with formulation the ordinary
has always put out products that have
minimal formulation
this drastically cuts down product
development and production costs which
is a large part of why their products
are
so cheap so for simpler products that
are basically just the active ingredient
dissolved into solution and then
adjusted to the right pH
that is probably fine so these are
things like simple hydroxy acid
solutions
with more complex products like
emulsions and things with unstable
actives and actives that are just harder
to get into your skin
then having a bit more formulation is
probably going to
make sure that that product actually
works so that those active ingredients
actually get into your skin where
they're needed
and do what they're meant to do and so
with those ones i think it's a little
bit more risky to use an ordinary
product i guess it's not really risky
it's just
it might not work but it's still really
accessible and really cheap and so the
fact that it's not working as well as it
could
is generally not a huge issue for people
who are going to the ordinary to just
experiment with different products
which i think is great with the powders
obviously there's zero formulation
which means that it's even more
questionable whether or not they work
which i can mostly forgive
because there are a lot of brands out
there including really sciencey brands
that don't test their products on skin
for the niacinamide powder the ordinary
recommend that you mix it with a
water-based product that's between pH
5.1 and 7.0
now i really doubt that people are going
to be measuring the pH
of what they're mixing it with but the
ordinary does have a list of their own
serums that they recommend mixing it
with so again
i don't think this is a huge problem but
i do think there is a bigger problem of
safety here
i think there's a bit of a trend in skin
care to be chasing higher and higher
percentages
this ties in with a lot of other ideas
that you hear a lot about in skin care
so the idea that if you have a low
percentage of actives then your product
is useless
that you need to look for products that
have actives in the top five ingredients
that honest skin care brands will give
you the percentages of every single
ingredient in their product
a lot of brands have encouraged this or
accidentally encouraged this including
the ordinary
by listing their percentages on their
products really clearly
without talking more about how that
isn't the
be-all and end-all of whether or not a
skincare product's good
in some cases they also use much much
higher percentages than their
competitors
and use this as a selling point but high
percentages
aren't necessary and a lot of the time
putting a higher percentage than you're
meant to in a product is actually bad
formulating practice if you buy cosmetic
ingredients from a manufacturer then on
their product data sheet they usually
tell you the recommended percentages for
a particular ingredient
so with niacinamide for example it's
usually recommended at 0.5 to 5 percent
with l ascorbic acid it's recommended
at five to fifteen percent
the reason there's an upper limit on
these percentages isn't because they're
trying to trick you
and get more money out of you because if
you think about it the ingredient
suppliers are actually going to make
more money and sell more product
if they get cosmetic formulators to use
more of their active ingredients
the reason is that scientific studies
have already found really good effects
at these levels
and they haven't actually found better
effects at higher levels the higher
levels have never been used in
scientific studies
there's no real reason to use them if
you're looking for skin brightening
because
it actually hasn't been tested and in
general if you have
a high percentage the more likely it is
you'll have side effects
so the likely irritation and stress to
your skin probably isn't worth it for
that
theoretical extra benefit so you might
be gaining this much irritation and only
this much extra effect or even no extra
effect
an analogy is food so there's going to
be a lot of food analogies here because
i really like food
so pepper for example if you like pepper
a bit of pepper in your food is good
maybe a bit more pepper is even better
but at some point there is just going to
be too much pepper
so given these recommended percentages
you'll notice that a lot of the time in
skincare products you get
a higher percentage than is recommended
on the one hand this is good because if
you have like a not very well formulated
product
then that high percentage means that
more of it is likely to get into your
skin so the same amount as if you had
a well-formulated product at a lower
percentage if it's an ingredient that's
a bit unstable then maybe that also
means that
some of it will degrade before it gets
to you and so you're left with
the amount that you actually wanted so
again this
might compensate for a bad formulation
but on the other hand there is an upper
recommended percentage for a good reason
firstly it's the efficacy studies and
secondly it's the side effects of things
like irritation and toxicology
so you'll often hear from cosmetic
science mythbusters like me and jen of
the eco well
that ingredients are safe in products at
the concentrations they're
used the important part here is at the
concentrations used in beauty products
if there's too much it might not
actually be fine
so toxicologists have analyzed the
safety of these ingredients
based on the amounts that are commonly
used in products
if you have 75% of something rather than
the recommended 5%
then it might not be fine anymore so for
example the cosmetic ingredient review
which is an organization that does a lot
of this toxicology
testing and assessing of ingredients has
this to say about niacinamide
based on the available data the cir
expert panel concludes that niacinamide
and niacin are safe
in the current practices of use and
concentration in cosmetic
products so the highest concentration
products that they looked at in their
review was actually only three percent
this was done in 2001 when niacinamide
wasn't such a hot ingredient
for ascorbic acid the highest
concentration was 10% that they looked at
and they have a really similar statement
as well
based on the available data contained in
this report the cir expert panel
concludes that l-ascorbic acid
is safe as used in cosmetic products so
these safety reviews usually give a
really wide margin of error for
long-term health effects
so things like cancer and reproductive
problems so that means if you're using
multiple products with five percent
niacinamide or 10% l-ascorbic acid and
you're using them multiple times a day
you're probably not going to be risking
any of these there's also the fact that
these two particular ingredients
are vitamins that humans have been using
and eating for
as long as humans have been around but
one of the side effects that can happen
if you have a little bit more of an
ingredient than you should
is irritation so in these safety
assessments the highest concentrations
that they tested for irritancy was
twenty percent for niacinamide
and ten percent for l-ascorbic acid and
for these ingredients most of the
studies that found beneficial effects
were done at less than five percent
niacinamide
and less than 10% l ascorbic acid so
there's no reliable evidence that having
a higher concentration than these will
actually give more benefits
and there's actually a study that
suggests that going higher than 20% l
ascorbic acid
doesn't give you more benefits but will
increase irritation
unfortunately for the ordinary's
products there's not much guidance that
they give
to give you five percent niacinamide or
ten percent L-ascorbic acid
and in fact it's like so vague they
don't even
emphasize any of the importance of this
maths so for the l-ascorbic acid they
say to mix a small amount and for the
niacinamide they say mix a quarter
scoop
so this guidance is my biggest issue
with these powders
my overall complaint is that you can't
measure a tiny amount of a powder
accurately at home
so the small amount that you're meant to
use of the ascorbic acid is just so
incredibly vague
if you ask five different people to show
you what they think a small amount of a
powder is they're going to show you five
wildly different amounts
so with the niacinamide the guidance is
a little bit better they tell you to use
a quarter scoop and they give you the
scoop
with the product but there's still a ton
of problems with this
so firstly a scoop is what we call a
volumetric measurement so you're seeing
how much stuff you can cram into a
particular volume
volumetric measurements of items are
never really that reliable
so we know this from everyday life so if
you go and get a box of salads some
places will pack it full of salad
and some places will give you like a
couple of leaves that expand to fill the
whole container
and so you get wildly different amounts
of salad you get very different amounts
of fullness from that salad even though
both
are a box even when it's something
relatively solid like let's say
strawberries you still get a really wide
range of amounts because you can have
large strawberries you can chop them up
into finely diced strawberries and you
can fit a lot more of that finely diced
strawberry into that cup
even with something like a powder where
the range of sizes is pretty small
you can still get things like a tightly
packed cup of flour versus a loosely
packed cup of flour
so even with this sort of powder where
it looks like it's all the same size
if you zoom in there's actually a whole
bunch of different sizes
so if you have a jar of powder with
different sizes of powder which they
almost always have then what's going to
happen is that the bigger particles tend
to stay at the top
and the smaller particles filter down to
the bottom and so
when you're up the top you're scooping
up bigger particles which means you get
less mass
in your scoop when you get down to the
bottom then you end up with a more
tightly packed powder
and so you end up with a greater
percentage and with things like skincare
that percentage is based on mass not on
volume so it's not like
five percent is one scoop per 20 scoops
it is one mass per 20 masses and so
that's going to make a difference
now in my diy vitamin c recipe i did
give a volumetric measurement as an
approximation
and that's because i realized that not
everyone has scales at home
and so giving an approximate volumetric
measurement is probably better than
nothing
better than add a small amount anyway
there's also a really wide range of
l-ascorbic acid concentrations that are
both safe and effective so between five
and twenty percent if you aim for ten
percent that means you have a hundred
percent leeway either way
and so if you're measuring a large
amount like a whole teaspoon of powder
then you have a lot of leeway it's
really hard to be out by a hundred
percent
and that's one of my biggest issues with
these powders they recommend that you do
it per dose so
each time you put it on your face you
measure out the small amount
with my diy serum you are making 20 mL
at a time
and so when you're measuring a larger
amount you have a smaller percentage
error
and this is the reason i've never
recommended making up your vitamin c per
dose
so what i mean by percentage error is
let's say you're trying to make a 10%
vitamin c serum to put on your face
if you're making 20 ml of serum you need
to measure out two grams of powder
if you accidentally add an extra five
milligrams so this is like a match head
size amount
then it isn't a big issue if you've
recalculated that means you've
accidentally made a 10.025%
serum which is not a big deal a lot of
commercial
ascorbic acid serums probably regularly
accidentally add this much extra
but if you're mixing a single dose of
serum let's say about 0.2 mL which is
how much i use
you're going to need two milligrams of
l-ascorbic acid now
this time if you accidentally add an
extra five milligrams you aren't going
to be 0.025%
out you are 25% out so this is what i
mean by a larger percentage error
you are using way more concentrated
stuff than you should be
this is higher than any commercial
vitamin c serum you are using a product
that's three and a half times stronger
than you wanted
one of the things that really annoys me
about the new niacinamide powder is that
they recommend that you use a quarter
scoop of the included scoop
why didn't they just give you the right
scoop size there is like a big
mathematical problem with
this sort of hemisphere scoop and that
is a quarter scoop is not what you
expect
so you think a quarter scoop is like a
quarter of the way up the spoon
it's actually closer to a third of the
way up the spoon and so it's really hard
to eyeball that
like with a circle circles are smaller
at the bottom with a sphere it is like a
circle but worse
it's like a circle like a whole bunch of
times
there's also the fact that you're not
going to be scooping the powder
perfectly horizontally
like that or like that you're probably
going to be scooping it diagonally and
so that makes it even harder to eyeball
how much you need
so i don't know why they didn't give the
right scoop size i'm guessing it's
something to do with not being able to
find the right scoop size
some sort of supply issue if i was a
more cynical person i might even suggest
that it's because
that way they can blame the customer if
they have any like
real irritation issues and so they can
spread some of that negligence but
yeah i don't know it's the wrong scoop
size and that's really annoying
so on top of the wildly variable amounts
of l-ascorbic acid and niacinamide that
you're putting on your face
there's also the issue of pH for
niacinamide it's not as bad niacinamide
is mostly pH neutral
and so you're not going to get any sort
of safety issue l-ascorbic acid is an
acid
and so that means when you put it into
any water-based solution it's going to
donate extra H+
into the solution and that's what
burns your face off
with my diy serum you adjust the pH back
up to a safe level using baking soda
that means you get a nice 3 to 3.5 which
is still effective without being
actually dangerous there's no
neutralization step here so if you have
a 10% solution
that could go down to pH 2. if you have
a higher percentage like you might
accidentally do with your small amount
and your match head size
that completely ruins your concentration
then you might have an even lower pH
that is like not good
that is like the apple cider vinegar
burn your face off territory
so i don't really like doing highly
negative reviews of products
because i think that in general with
most products someone out there will
enjoy it
there will be a place for it somewhere
and like i said i like a lot of deciem
products i think a lot of them are
really good
a lot of them work really well for my
skin and they're so budget friendly that
it's really
accessible for everyone but in this case
i really think there is a clear safety
issue with these products and how they
tell you to use these products
there are some very good reasons why
other brands haven't done this before
even though it's so easy to do
to just like chuck raw materials into a
jar and sell it on and it's really
profitable as well
this bit is probably just my inner cheap
ass but the L-ascorbic acid powder
isn't even good value
you can get 250 grams from iherb for
9.90
and so if you scoop out the same amount
in this jar this would be 80 cents worth
so i think there's a lot of science
washing a lot of like science theater
going on with this product
and i think it's important for people
who are thinking of buying this product
to know why
having your product and then mixing
things into it and sort of like playing
chemist without proper scales without
proper pH testing
might not be the best idea it's also a
bit frustrating to see people get so
excited about this product even though
every cosmetic chemist i've talked to
has been like this is an awful idea
i wouldn't even trust myself to do this
at home let alone someone who
doesn't know how to do the right
calculations doesn't know how to do the
right procedures
and at the same time people are
criticizing properly formulated products
for being unsafe when they use any of
those
buzzy so-called toxic ingredients so
things like alcohol
parabens fragrance and dyes even though
they're all included
at low enough concentrations to be
considered safe according to
lots of actual toxicological
calculations and considerations
there's just so much science behind
those products showing that they are
safe whereas with these ones every
scientist i've talked to has been like
no so i guess the main message is
marketing is something that we have to
be aware of and it comes from both
brands that are natural
organic and clean and no toxins
as well as from the more sciencey brands
as well anyway
leave me a comment letting me know what
you think about this issue if you liked
it click the like subscribe
you can also check out my instagram and
check out my blog for more nerdy beauty
talk
see you next time